there was a part of me bets  that's real innit that's a good man is  an honest man in there and there's Sugar  Ray Leonard who was Eagle German who was  a tough sob in the ring who had money  who had Fame and at some point I didn't  really appreciate it but took took  advantage of that and in my first wife  Juanita she always said you know you you  two different people and I just get  angry about that they gonna have a drink  but then when my my present wife  Bernadette said to me you to you I knew  there was a problem  many many moments many many nights or  days I will wake up and and not remember  what what the hell just happened that  night I always knew I had a problem just  never admitted it to myself I never  believed it and that's deadly that's  wrong one day I woke up nine years ago I  woke up and life couldn't be better  where are they now all new Saturday 10/9  central